you you're getting ready you know you
talked about hitting the road this
summer how was how does touring life
today different in comparison what it
was 10 20 different it's different it's
very different like I bring my son with
me he's 8 years old so a large portion
of my energy is spent making sure that
he's having fun getting an education
seeing the world understanding places
that we go to I didn't used to have that
at all you know I eat differently I
sleep differently I think differently
I'm still just as excited about going I
think it's easier now it's it's less
less destructive and less torturous than
when you're first starting out and you
push so hard that you just break
yourself try not to do that so much I
try to go for the marathon run a bit
more than the 50-yard dash when I'm out
there like I don't want to blow my wad
the first two nights out and like lose
my voice for the rest of the tour so I'm
kind of like I've got to do this for the
next year
let's get strong and run for the long
run how is you know it must be amazing
having your son
to experience the kind of things you're
going to but how is how's fatherhood
changing uh changed me I think I've just
gained a lot from my son yeah you know
he he's my guy that's my guy and then
you can't really understand until you
get there it doesn't make sense you see
your friends with kids and they're all
into it you're like I love those kids
you can't really feel it until you feel
it so it's a gift to me you know he's
the gift to me being around him I feel
like I get more than I give I try to
give him all I got but I feel like I
still get more so it's changed me in the
way that I'm I'm fuller now is he a
barometer all for your music um yeah
there's only one song he's not in love
with on this record but overall yeah he
likes this record better than anything
we've done in the past and he can sing
every lyric on this new record so he's a
barometer when I see him smile and when
I see him look at me like you wrote that
dad it's a good feeling how do you you
know I always wonder for a lot of you
know musicians such as yourself or
people of notoriety who grew up in a
certain facet a certain way I always
wonder how do you instill that same
hunger and indifferent and maybe you
know the adversity sometimes you face
growing up that makes you into the
individual you are how do you give you
know your son who's obviously afforded
opportunities that you never had growing
up how do you give him that same kind of
those same experiences I don't think I'm
gonna have to give it to him I think the
world has a way of giving us struggles
even when you're born into a world where
you have a house and you have food and
you have a school and you have a father
who's gonna keep the world as safe as
possible for you the universe knows what
it has to do and he's gonna find his
struggles I don't have to give them to
him no one ever gave me my struggles I
found them myself
so I'm sure he'll find them I hope they
don't hurt too bad but I know that's
what's gonna make him grow and that's
his experience I'll pray for the
strength to accept whatever he has to go
through because I know it'll hurt me to
see him in pain of any kind
but you know maybe he's gonna be that
guy that just doesn't have to go through
quite as much hurt as his dad yeah which
would be awesome for ya yeah let him
have his hurts along the way but if it
doesn't have to be all the way down and
dirty that's fine
he's listening he's learning piano yeah
and he's a natural-born vocalist he
likes singing and we like writing songs
daily about anything and everything